veamos si podemos aplicar lo que sabemos
de números negativos y lo que sabemos de
exponentes para aplicar exponentes a
números negativos consideremos primero
supongamos que tenemos menos 3 elevado a
la potencia 1 esto que es igual bueno
este simplemente menos 3 así de simple
menos 3 elevado a la primera potencia es
menos 3 ahora consideremos menos 3
elevado a la segunda potencia menos 3 al
cuadrado eso qué quiere decir eso
significa que si tomamos dos veces menos
3 si tomamos dos veces menos 3 y lo
multiplicamos eso va a ser menos 3 al
cuadrado y esto a cuanto es igual bueno
menos por menos es más
3 por 3 es 9 esto es igual a 9 positivo
esto es igual a 9 continuemos con esta
secuencia para ver si encontramos un
patrón hagamos menos 3 elevado a la
tercera potencia menos 13 al cubo
esto que es igual esto es igual a tomar
menos 3 3 veces menos 3 3 veces y hacer
la multiplicación de estos menos 3 esto
nos da menos 3 x menos 39 que acabamos
de calcular y eso hay que multiplicarlo
por menos 3 positivo por negativo es
negativo así es que esto es igual a
menos 27 y aquí ya notamos un patrón
cuando elevamos un número negativo
cuando elevamos un número negativo a un
exponente impar cuando elevamos un
número negativo a un exponente impar el
resultado va a ser un número negativo el
resultado va a ser un número negativo
pues el número negativo al multiplicarlo
por un número negativo que tendría una
potencia par sería positivo pero al
multiplicarlo otra vez un número
negativo que será una potencia impar se
ve un número negativo y qué pasa cuando
una base negativa un número negativo lo
elevamos a un exponente
bueno en este caso cuando tú multiplicas
negativo por negativo vas a tener un
número positivo si lo vuelves a
multiplicar por negativo que sería un
número impar de veces vas tener un
número negativo pero al volverlo
multiplicado otra vez por negativo ya
estarías elevándolo un número par de
veces y obtendrías un positivo es decir
cuando un número negativo se eleva a una
potencia par se obtiene un número
positivo así es que no hay nada nuevo en
realidad en esto de elevar números
negativos a un exponente lo único que
tenemos que recordar es que cuando
multiplicamos un número negativo por un
número negativo tenemos un número
positivo y que si multiplicamos un
número positivo por un número negativo
obtenemos un número negativo pero eso ya
lo sabíamos desde que aprendimos a
multiplicar números negativos hay otro
aspecto que quiero dejar en claro pues
en ocasiones puede ser ambiguo
supongamos que tienes esta expresión
supón que te encuentras con esta
expresión te invito a que pongas pausa
en el vídeo y pienses cómo evaluar esta
expresión
ahora que ya intentaste esta piensa como
se evaluaría entonces esta auto
expresión
bien si vamos a evaluar la primera si
seguimos la regla de la presidencia de
las operaciones aquí lo primero que
tendríamos que hacer es elevar a la
potencia 3 y luego multiplicar por menos
1 que es lo que está indicando aquí este
signo menos así es que esto sería menos
1 por 2 elevado al cubo por lo cual
muchas veces esto se va a interpretar
como menos 2 elevado al cubo y esto va a
ser igual a menos 8 ahora de este lado
tenemos menos 2 elevado al cubo hacemos
la operación y esto también nos va a dar
menos 8 entonces tú puedes decir cuál es
el problema si el resultado es igual
bien pero qué pasaría si éstos fueran
exponentes pares supongamos que ahora
tienes déjame hacer un poco más de
espacio aquí supongamos que ahora tienes
menos 4 al cuadrado menos 4 al cuadrado
y también tienes menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado claramente esto es menos 4 x
menos 4 que es 16 menos por menos es más
4 el cuadro 16 y aquí que tenemos
hacemos primero 4 al cuadrado 4 al
cuadrado y vamos a multiplicar por menos
1 sería menos 4 por 4 y esto es igual a
menos
16 es muy importante tener esto en
cuenta pues si lo que se quiere es tener
como base un número negativo que se está
elevando a una potencia hay que poner la
base entre paréntesis